[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: I'm very
pleased to welcome you all,
and to welcome a
very esteemed author.
Not just an author,
but someone I
consider a genuine friend here.
Ryan Williams.
He and I went to
university together.
And he has a very
esteemed background
that I think a lot of you are
familiar with and have seen.
And I'd appreciate
it if you'd all
give him a round of applause
to welcome Ryan to the stage.
[APPLAUSE]
RYAN WILLIAMS: Thank you.
Thank you everyone here.
It's a pleasure to be up
in Mountain View at Google.
So I'd like to start
off by giving you all
self a round of applause
for coming out today
and spending some time to
talk about influencers.
So get up for yourselves.
[APPLAUSE]
So this book is called
"The Influencer Economy."
It's about how to launch your
idea, share it with the world,
and thrive in the digital age.
So today we'll be
thinking about how
we can influence others
to collaborate, to share
our ideas, to help build
products people love,
because ultimately
when you collaborate
with your community,
your customers,
and influential leaders in your
field, you become an influencer
yourself.
So this all started for me
when I was 22 years old.
I'm a former clinically
depressed person.
And I say this because I was
22, living in Washington DC.
And you can only imagine what
my apartment looked like.
I had beer bottles and soda
cans strewn across the floor.
My bed was never made
for weeks at a time.
I had dishes all over the
kitchen that were stacked up
like you couldn't believe.
I struggled to breathe.
And I went to my day
job as my main outlet.
In order to get over the
hump of being depressed,
I did what any rational
person would do.
I became a stand-up comedian,
because why wouldn't you
want to be a clinically
depressed stand-up comedian
where your main goal is to make
strangers laugh at comedy clubs
with their arms folded,
drunk off flat beer,
eating greasy chicken wings.
Imagine this scenario with
the smoky bars in Baltimore,
Washington DC, where your main
goal is to make them laugh.
How do you think it went?
If you find out a way for it
to go well, please let me know.
My parents, my therapists,
and my now wife
who was then my
girlfriend at the time,
they were curious themselves.
What I learned a lot
about through stand-up
was putting yourself out there
and dealing with rejection
is what makes the
experience unique.
And I ultimately
pivoted my career.
I listened to the
market that told me--
again, I'll let you be the
decider if I was funny or not.
But I ultimately
listened to the market.
And I was a marketing
pro at stand-up.
And I could fill amphitheaters
and comedy venues and dive bars
all over DC.
And I Comedy Central comedians
call me up, texting me, saying,
I headline at my show
and five people come.
But you can get 250.
What's your secret?
And that's when I
realized I could
pivot my career into marketing.
And my aspirations
of being an artist
were going to be put
on hold temporarily.
So I left the comedy world
and I moved to Los Angeles.
And I worked at a
couple of companies.
I helped raise venture
capital and run marketing.
And as Googlers, who here is
familiar with machinima.com?
We are a multichannel network,
for those that don't know.
I see a lot of
people are familiar.
We're a gaming
network on YouTube.
So think about ESPN for gamers,
where the sports instead
of being football, or soccer,
they are Call of Duty,
they are Minecraft.
And who here has played
the game Minecraft?
Better question-- whose kids or
cousins have played Minecraft?
OK.
More hands have showed up,
because ultimately, Minecraft
was a game that we helped launch
at Machinima with no budget.
And I realized that our sales
team was functioning really
well.
But we had no marketing.
So we're young.
We're energetic.
We needed marketing collateral.
We launched our social
media and our branding.
And we had a hungry team.
And we were building
this amazing product.
You all, the majority of the
room are technologists here.
So you know the power of
building a tech solution
and how exciting it is.
So we were acquired
by Warner Brothers
a couple of months
ago for $100 million.
And ultimately, Machinima was
one of the pioneering groups
I've ever seen to galvanize
a community because we
built our products
with the community.
Our alpha, our beta, our launch.
And our customers--
like with Minecraft,
which sold for $2.5
billion to Microsoft--
they built it.
And we helped them,
because we let everyone
into the creative process.
So I was fascinated
by influence, right.
And the word
"influencer" has been
hijacked-- it's been hijacked
by a bunch of no-talent zeros.
Just because you get a
bunch of likes on Instagram
because you're sexy, or these
jeans make you look sexy,
it doesn't matter.
Right?
Influencers does
not equal followers.
Influencers do not
equal impressions.
Influence is something where
you want to make a dent in life.
You want to be known.
And if we look back in 20
years, Google will exist.
I mean, it's up to you all
to keep it in business.
But Google will
exist in 20 years.
And we will Google peoples'
names for influence.
And we're not going to find
some Instagram celebrity.
We're not going to find
someone who looks hot in jeans
and was paid $25,000 to
tweet about a product.
That is not what
an influencer is.
So an influencer,
to me, is "someone
who can create a movement
around their idea
through collaboration, community
passion, and a shared vision."
It's something connective,
because ultimately,
collaboration is where
influence is derived.
And influencers can
change a small idea
into a world-changing
one seemingly overnight,
because something small could
become big because influencers
can endorse these ideas.
And also, influence is
gained through collaboration,
often in a niche community.
Like we did at Machinima,
we'll be Minecraft gamers
in a very specific game.
We made videos around it.
We built that community.
And finally, influence has
nothing to do with impressions,
has nothing to do
with followers,
and it has nothing to do
with any vanity metric.
Vanity metrics are
not real word metrics.
And how I know this is
because I did some research
because I live in LA.
And everyone there is
obsessed with celebrity.
And Kim Kardashian
and Ryan Seacrest
are your textbook celebrities.
So I went into their data.
And what I found was our
Machinima influencers
could move the needle.
We had hundreds of thousands
of YouTube subscribers
on these channels.
Anyone here watch
the Machinima video?
It's a bunch of game play,
oftentimes people narrating
over Minecraft.
And so imagine instead of
watching a football game
with the announcers, that
someone's playing Minecraft
and telling funny
stories about their life.
They're called vlogs.
Right.
Video logs.
They're really big in YouTube.
So these gamers that had
hundreds of thousands
of subscribers would make
videos playing Minecraft,
just educating people about the
world that was in Minecraft.
And in aggregate,
these influencers
with less celebrity
followers like these mascots
up here, they were influencers
because in their communities
in clusters of five to 10, these
influencers moved the needle.
And I think people like
Seacrest, people like Kim
Kardashian, they add value.
They drive traffic.
People watch their TV shows.
They're cultural taste makers.
But they are not true
social media influencers,
because again, the
word has been hijacked.
And they aren't no-talent zeros
like a lot of these influencers
are on Instagram, because
they do add value.
But ultimately I
want to show you
the data around why they're
not influential online.
So this is a slide
literally I made years ago
when I was working
doing research
on celebrity investments
and startups,
and how they move the
needle, because again,
every Silicon Valley
product, they want
to connect with a celebrity.
And they say, I
want to get someone
to tweet about my product.
It will be an overnight success.
And that is wrong.
Celebrities don't
move the needle
as much as very targeted,
specific niche influencers.
So this is Kim.
When she had a tweet, again,
I ripped this directly
from a deck I made years ago.
Anyone here familiar with Bitly,
the data tracking software
you can use to share links?
So she shared an
episode of "Keeping up
with the Kardashians"
to preview an episode.
And she got around
83,000 clicks on Twitter.
Right?
She has 18 million followers.
So that conversion is less
than a banner ad would be.
Banner ads are terrible.
Like who hear clicks on
banner ads on purpose?
Oftentimes I get mad, because
I actually click on it,
and I'm go back!
Go back!
So ultimately, the influencers
are very niche and targeted.
And Kim is super broad.
So here you can see that she's
around 0.46 of a percent.
Banner ads on average are
around half of a percent.
So you may as well go spend a
bunch of money on banner ads
if you can spend a bunch of cash
to get Kim Kardashian to tweet
about your product, or
your club opening in Vegas,
or anything relevant
to her community,
because she has a
broad celebrity.
She's a mascot.
And what's equally
fascinating about this data
is you notice the decay up here.
In the first 48 hours is where
the bulk of her traffic comes.
So nothing is being recycled.
Nothing is being circulated
amongst other influencer
communities to
keep this thriving.
Unlike the Minecraft
videos, which
are more timeless,
more evergreen,
and more personality-driven.
So all this fascination after I
left Machinima and I love what
we were doing-- those big ideas
we built the marketing team--
I went on to some other
startups and helped them
raise capital and do marketing.
But ultimately, I believe that
the world is so fascinating
right now, because you can
make a dent in doing something
that you can leave
influence around.
And then ultimately
there's a bartering
and there is an
exchange of ideas.
And we truly have
navigated a new economy.
So I wrote this book
to help us learn
how to operate in
this new economy,
and helping to teach others--
because learning is
really the fundamental
of how we exchange ideas.
And oftentimes giving
value is what matters.
And that's how we
navigate this new world.
So Seth Godin.
He's a fellow speaker at Google.
I interviewed over
100 influencers
for my podcast, which is called
"Stories from the Influencer
Economy," because I
wanted to build up
an idea and a platform
ahead of my book launch.
So I talked to Adam Grant--
anyone see his talk here?
It's a really good talk--
Dorie Clark, and many other
influential business writers.
And I took their application.
And I applied their old
knowledge with new influencers
in the social media space.
So Seth, why we'll
be talking about
him is because
he's an influencer.
He'll be around in 20 years
when you Google his name.
So he talks about
a tribe, and how
a tribe is a group of people
connected to one another,
connected to a leader,
connected to an idea.
For millions of
years, human beings
have been part of
one tribe or another.
A group needs only two
things to be a tribe.
A shared interest, and
a way to communicate.
Your company at Google
is led by tribes.
Everyone who has different
teams from research to tech,
you have a tribe leader.
And you are interested
in connecting.
And that's ultimately
what happens
with storytelling and sharing of
ideas and why someone like Seth
is an influencer.
So these are the chapters of
the book, which you all got,
in emoji.
I researched his book years ago.
I did this slide to
connect with millennials,
because my parents
didn't use emoji.
But now my parents use emoji.
So this slide is
really for everyone.
But ultimately, the emoji
chapters of the book
are how you craft
your big vision.
Every influencer I talk to
has a big vision, a big idea,
to sell you on something.
Like Sergei and Larry years
ago, they had this big vision
to solve a problem.
Because you need buy-in from
people to believe in what
you're doing.
Secondly is you pick a platform.
I picked the
suitcase emoji here,
because you've got to pick
somewhere you're going.
And you need a channel.
So it's no longer, oh,
I want to go to coffee
and pick your brain.
Right?
Those people drive me nuts.
I don't know.
Sorry if anyone here does that.
Sorry, not sorry, actually.
Because ultimately, you want
to collaborate with someone.
And you pick a channel.
It could be building an alpha
version of your product.
It could be you make
YouTube content.
For me, it was podcasting.
And ultimately, we were
building these relationships
because that's what is currency
in the influencer economy.
The next thing is a
book your own gigs.
You have to deal with
rejection, like Jay-Z. Actually,
this is the only
emoji that I invented.
I thought Jay-Z
would need an emoji.
I mean, who doesn't?
If anyone earned an
emoji, it's Jay-Z.
So you got to deal
with rejection.
You have to build relationships.
And you have to accept failure.
And you have to do every job.
And I grew up in
Des Moines, Iowa.
And it's known for corn farming.
And I like to say,
never build in a silo.
Never build by yourself.
I mean, this company was founded
in a garage in Silicon Valley
and Stanford.
But that stereotype is over.
People need to
build with others.
You have to share.
Because you need psychological
and behavioral buy-in
from people to help make
your idea better, and then
moreover help spreading it.
The next is adopt
technology early and often.
Influencers are always
curious around technology.
They need to find
tech as a solution.
And they can't be tech phobics.
The next one is striving
for authenticity.
And authenticity is a
word that's overused.
I love the word and
I hate the word.
Who here likes the
word "authentic"?
Who here doesn't like the word?
Right.
So it's a very branded word.
It's like influencer, right?
It's been hijacked by a
bunch of no-talent zeros.
So we're taking
it back right now,
because authenticity really
means having a strong message
and being comfortable in your
own skin, and being affable,
being likable because
you are who you are.
And ultimately we have flaws.
And we have characteristics
that we can't always execute on.
I wish I could say that
every word coming out today
will be perfect.
But the more likely I am to
admit that I'm not perfect,
the more likely
I'll be authentic.
And you only know
authenticity when you see it.
And then we have collaboration,
which we'll talk about a lot
today.
The fist bump.
Capturing lightning in a bottle.
That's something that you know
like, when you double down
or you need to pivot
with your idea,
because you have
that moment where
you know what your
customers are telling you,
that they either love it
or they want you to go back
to the drawing board.
And then ultimately, you got
to meet people in real life.
You can't rely on the internet.
You people live
streaming at home,
hopefully I'll get to
meet you in person.
But ultimately, you can't
sit back and passively
watch things on a laptop.
Influencers and
influential people
go out and meet
people in real life.
And finally, you
have to be a giver.
You have to open doors
for other people.
And then you have to give
people ownership of your idea.
You have to let them buy
in and celebrate with you,
your wins and your losses.
Because I have a
metaphor with Benihana.
Who here has been to Benihana?
You know how they cook
the food in front of you?
They let you into
the creative process.
And you get to see the
chef and they do tricks.
And you see what
you're about to eat.
And there's something
psychologically fun about that.
You get to meet
people at a table
that you don't ordinarily know.
I used to celebrate
my birthdays there
when I was younger, growing
up in Des Moines, Iowa.
And we loved it because
you'd celebrate with others.
So you have to figure
out a way to cook
with the community
and your customers
to get them to buy in.
So these are the three types
of collaboration styles.
And there's the collaborators.
This is roughly 10% of your
customer and community base.
These folks are the techies,
what I call the regulars.
They're the ones
you build the alpha,
and they're going to show
up like they would at a bar,
drinking with their friends
every Friday at happy hour.
They're the happy hour crew.
Right?
The regulars, they're
the one, they're
going to buy it when
you pilot your program
and give it out at a discount.
Because you need to
build these people
as your proof of concept.
And ultimately, they
become early adopters.
They become your
brand ambassadors.
And for me with my book,
getting it out to my friends,
my family, my email list,
psychologically a lot of people
wanted to help me because they
were part of the process early.
And so these are
your collaborators.
They validate it.
Because people make mistakes.
And they want to go
to influencers early.
And they pitch influencers.
And they fall on their face.
Because influencers
are the next group.
But you have to build
the proof of concept
out before you get the
key stakeholders involved.
I use the word "key
stakeholder" because we're
at a corporate company, right?
Isn't key stakeholder like,
the most corporate word ever?
Like, I talk in front
of tech entrepreneurs.
And I never mention that word.
So you at home,
just let you know,
I'm giving it to you as a
very corporate branding here,
because ultimately, I think
that the influencers are the one
percenters that you have to have
something to offer before they
want to work with you.
And you don't want
to burn that bridge,
because ultimately, they
are the industry leaders.
They are the authorities.
They are the one to
give you social proof.
And they're your
lead generators.
If you find the right
influencer to collaborate
with-- and again, don't
ask them just for coffee.
Ask them to review your
alpha to get feedback
to make your product better.
You don't want to ask them to
tweet about it, because that's
unbecoming.
And you also don't want
to ask them for a favor.
You don't want to
have someone feel
like they owe you something.
Like psychologically,
influence comes from a win-win,
from a mutual you
help me, I help you.
And we'll talk more
about this later
about giving as a big
philosophy for influence.
And the final step here
is the mass marketers.
People don't care,
often if influencers
endorse your product.
When someone buys
a Nest product,
they just care that it works.
They don't care that you had
an ambassador program, that you
had early adopters, that
you had a bunch of people
that gave you feedback,
and you got into Best Buy.
They just want it at Best Buy.
And so ultimately, the
consumers, the buyers,
the mass market, they're
about 90% of the groups.
So you want to build
something for them.
And it's fully baked.
And they're going to buy
it because it's already
established.
So getting into a couple of key
principles here of the book.
This is the platform rule.
My father-in-law
is named Joe Moore.
Who here is married?
Of you, you know what
father-in-laws are all about.
Sometimes you love them.
Sometimes whatever the
opposite of love is,
that's how you feel.
So my father-in-law, he has no
idea what I do in California.
He says how are these
startups valued at hundreds
of millions of dollars?
What do you do to add
that value to the company?
Where's the money coming in?
Because he runs a
boiler repair company
in Raleigh, North Carolina.
So I talked to him
about influence.
And he was really
curious about my book
and what I'm working on.
And I said, how do you
define the word "influence"?
And he said, look.
"You have to give
people something
they can't get anywhere
else in quite the same way."
And you have to
solve a pain point.
And he gave me an
example of sales.
So he has people calling
him up through the Southeast
for boiler problems.
He gives them free
advice for a half hour,
gives them just
enough information
that they're dangerous, and
then not enough information
that they can execute
on it, because they
don't have the resources.
So he says the problem
with so many people
is they don't know
how to solve problems.
And ultimately,
that's what happens
when you want to gain influence,
and you're not helping people,
you're not solving
a market demand.
Ultimately you have to
develop a knowledge or skill
that most people don't have.
And then you share it with them.
And you build that
proof of concept
that with your collaborators.
And then ultimately,
customers come
because you've built
something that you know
there's a massive demand for.
Anyone that works in YouTube
know who Hannah Hart is?
She's a wonderful human being.
She has a series called
"My Drunk Kitchen."
And guess what it's about?
Her drinking wine and
getting tipsy and making food
with her friends.
She's a massive success.
She turned it into a TV show.
She has a bestselling book
called "My Drunk Kitchen."
And she's done an amazing
job branding her idea.
But she is an endearing person.
And she did a Hello,
Harto tour, which
is a crowdfunding campaign.
And ultimately with
her, she shared with me
that you give now, and
people will pay later.
And you have to
hear their problems.
So she went out and she
galvanized her base,
because she knew
they wanted a tour.
She went around the
country in an RV.
And people who crowdfunded her
project at a certain threshold
were entered into a lottery.
And she went to your
house and drunk cooked,
and then made content around it.
So you're collaborating
in her videos.
Who here knows what
the term collab
means in the YouTube ecosystem?
It's not that technical.
It means what you think.
But collabing in YouTube is
when someone has a video series.
And let's say Peyton has a video
series about building a home
security system, cause
he works at Nest.
He's super into this category.
And let's say he has
100,000 YouTube subscribers.
Really compelling.
Super compelling guy.
Right?
100,000 subscribers
is no small feat.
Let's say the gentleman right
here in the green shirt,
let's say you have a
business vlog-- a video log--
where you talk about
CES mainstream products.
And let's say, what's a name
for your channel if you had one?
What's an interest of yours?
AUDIENCE: Food.
RYAN WILLIAMS: Food?
What?
Food.
So let's call it
Nerd Food Tech Zone.
And you have a million
subscribers, right?
And Peyton with his
channel has 100,000.
So you do a collab.
You appear in his niche
channel, do a video together.
You appear in Nerd
Food Blog Tech.
Is that what we called it?
Yeah.
And so you have a
massive channel.
So you collaborate.
There's no money exchanged.
Again, it's a bartering system.
You want to help make his
channel better and get him
new subscribers.
But then equally you know
that he's very niche,
and you can appear in his
videos and be in a super target
segment.
So you share audience.
And that bartering,
that collab, is really
where influence thrives.
I get back to the
win-win of it all.
You have to find a
mutually beneficial way
to collaborate with people.
It could be through money.
It could be through equity.
Or it could be through goodwill.
But that's what I learned
from all these YouTubers.
Years
And Brad Feld.
Anyone familiar with Brad?
He started Techstars.
It's a big startup accelerator
in Boulder, Colorado.
And they essentially
give $25,000 to $50,000
to early stage companies to help
them accelerate their ideas.
And Brad, he talks about how
you need to pilot your ideas.
And piloting your idea comes
down to testing something
where the barrier
to entry is low.
So Brad started blogging at
feld.com I would say back
in '05.
Right.
So now he's one of the
early adopter tech bloggers.
And his advice to me was, don't
always have a defined goal.
Sometimes start something
for curiosity's sake.
So he started Techstars,
which is a massive incubator
and accelerator.
He started it because he
could make new friends.
Or he could turn it into
a billion dollar business.
But most likely, it was going
to be somewhere in between.
So he's made new friends.
And they've invested in
thousands of startups.
And he's been there for
the early stage growth.
He's become a mentor in
the startup community.
He even talks about
topics like depression.
Like he came on my podcast
recently and talked
about OCD and depression,
because he wants to help
build communities.
And ultimately,
piloting your ideas
is something where
you can workshop
when the stakes are low.
Because if Nest
breaks down, people
get mad, because they paid a
lot of money for their product.
But if you're piloting something
with the barrier of entry low,
and you have no customers,
no one's using it,
you can make those mistakes
when no one's looking
and the bright
lights aren't on you.
So these guys are
the Vlog Brothers.
Has anyone seen
their work before?
The Vlog brothers
are these guys,
essentially they
started a conference
called VidCon, which
is a big YouTube
conference down in Anaheim.
And they started very small.
And their channel called
the Vlog Brothers,
they do science fiction,
or science videos.
And they did one
video blog a day
to each other for
an entire year.
So they did 365 videos.
And that's how they got started.
Right.
They started small.
So with influence,
it's like naming
your community is a
massive opportunity,
because they called their
community Nerd Fighters.
And you notice they have
the Spock fingers up here
on their thumbnail, because
naming and identifying
your community--
like you're Googlers.
Right?
That's a community identifier.
Having a community of people
that recognize themselves
can help you
galvanize that base.
And think about YouTubers.
Like, YouTubers,
that's the people
that make the YouTube
videos and have subscribers.
Like, there's a
connotation there.
So identifying your
customers, naming them--
even just internally-- helps
you galvanize that base.
And when you have an idea
with the customer in mind,
oftentimes there's two
ways to go about it.
One is you find that big vision,
and then you take a platform.
So for me, my big vision--
I'm going to write this
influencer economy book.
And I started my podcast to
connect with influencers,
to connect with audiences,
because I'm a former stand-up
and I love doing that,
and to help tell stories
so people can learn.
But sometimes influencers and
people that are influential,
they start small with a vlog.
And that turns into
VidCon years later.
And these guys are
brilliant branders.
One of their catchphrases is
don't forget to be awesome.
That's assuming you're
already awesome.
And they're reminding
you not to forget it.
So I think that's
a wonderful way
to think about how to build
that relationship is you've got
to brand your ideas creatively.
And that's really where the
authenticity comes into play.
So another YouTuber I love is
this guy named Freddy Wong.
And it's funny, because
a lot of people,
they don't know who he is.
But if I ever have anyone under
the age of 16 in the crowd,
they love this guy.
He did a series called Video
Game High School, which
is like a Harry Potter for video
games, where in the future--
you all have seen it?
Like in the future, there
is gaming academies.
And these professional
gaming academies
are going to help
save the world.
It's amazing.
It's been viewed a
billion times online.
And he's crowdfunded three
campaigns for $2 million.
He was crowdfunding before
Spike Lee did it, you know,
before Veronica Mars, and before
all these mainstream Zach Braff
projects were on Kickstarter.
And I love how he used
technology to his advantage.
He figured out a way to leverage
tech and be an early adopter,
amass YouTube subscribers
back when YouTube
wasn't even monetizable.
And he makes sci-fi
videos that people love.
And his crowdfunding
campaign shattered records,
because ultimately, Freddie
had these amazing perks.
So I would take it
most people at Google
have supported a
crowdfunding campaign.
And I love crowdfunding
campaigns, right?
Because they give you
updates continually.
And so Freddie's perks
define the accessibility
of people with influence.
For $5,000 he had
a perk where you
could go with the cast and
crew of Video Game High School
to Disney for the day.
All you did do was
get to Anaheim.
And then you would
spend the whole day
on roller coaster rides
and Space Mountain
with Freddy and his buddies
that are in your favorite web
series.
He had another one
for $3,500, I believe,
where he would deliver fried
dough to your front door
anywhere in the country.
Or the local equivalent, if
you didn't have fried dough.
So glazed donuts.
And so luckily, he said that it
was a person in New Jersey who
bought that perk.
So he's in New York.
And he ships it over for work.
But ultimately, that
kind of cleverness,
leveraging the technology.
Can you imagine what would
Steven Spielberg even
say to you if he
was on your door?
Like, sorry, Steven,
if you're watching.
But I mean, I ask
the broader question
is, the celebrity is a
broad person with influence.
But Freddy is on
your mobile device.
He's on your laptop.
He's on your iPad.
He's someone that you have a
connected relationship with,
because he's truly influential.
And you're
collaborating with him.
I think everyone needs to--
if you haven't done a
crowdfunding campaign,
and you're watching
this, just support one.
Because those e-mails you
get, even when they are late
and the project's overdue,
they're with love.
And you buy something
and you preorder it
because you buy in and back it.
I think the backing
mentality is how marketers
win in the new economy.
You have to think of your
customers as backers,
and let them drive
to a larger goal
where you give them
a vision and say,
I'm going to execute on this.
I'll let you in on something
when I launched my book.
I had an email list
and some friends
that I sent the book
out to for free.
And it's relevant, because
I used a Google doc.
So I know my audience.
And I love Google Docs, right?
So I sent it out.
And I said, if you give
me an edit for the book--
and this was like months before
I was going to launch it--
if you give me any feedback,
if I use it or not,
I'll give you an editor
title in my book.
And I learned that from
crowdfunding campaigns,
because I saw people
that were-- you
could become an executive
producer for video series
and movies if you donated
a certain amount of money.
And my wife said,
that's a terrible idea.
Why would you give
your book out for free?
And what I learned was,
it was the best idea
I could have hatched,
because the people that
left me the comments
made my book better.
And I pivoted part of it.
And it actually had
more actions and lessons
for people to learn from.
Moreover, the first people
to buy my book at launch
and leave reviews on book sites
were my first cred editors.
And they all got in the book.
So psychologically
they built it with me.
I mean, I have a Gmail account,
which is pretty much my name.
I'm not going to give
it out to everyone.
Because I was a
early adopter, right?
And people love
getting access early.
And if you can figure out a
way to psychologically make
people feel part of
the process, then you
are going to be a winner.
So how's everyone doing?
We good?
Everyone good?
We're going to have some
questions afterward.
If you have questions
even now, as long as
you ask them politely, please.
I used to do stand-up comedy.
So this is a warmer crowd
than dive bars in Baltimore.
There's a smoky haze because
it's non-smoking in this room.
It's a couple of more examples
is the giver mentality.
Adam Grant-- he's
spoken at Google.
Have you seen his work?
"Give and Take."
It's a phenomenal book.
Adam's a Wharton professor
and a business consultant.
He talks about how givers
succeed more in life.
And takers, you obviously
know who they are.
Right?
They take the most in life.
And most of us are matchers.
So givers, takers, and matchers.
And matchers are people that
you help me, quid pro quo.
You scratch my back,
I scratch your back.
You want to collaborate
with those people, right?
But givers succeed the most,
and they fail the most.
Because you need to give with
your own self-interest aligned.
And you want to give
with your own interests,
because why give for
the sake of giving?
Because you get
taken advantage of.
And that's truly remarkable.
I wrote an article about why
giving and helping others
without expecting
anything in return
is the best business
model for life.
And I threw it up on
the website medium.com.
It's a blog engine.
And it's already
getting surfaced.
And it made its way to Adam.
And I ended up getting an
email introduction to him
because I wrote this article.
And oftentimes, putting yourself
out there, taking a chance,
even if it's a blog post
that no one's going to read.
Like I registered
influencereconomy.com years
ago.
And multiple companies ago.
I knew I was never going to
be able to write the book when
I had a crazy intense job.
But I bookmarked it.
I wrote a blog post.
Well, I wanted
Google SEO as well,
because I don't want people
searching influencer economy
and having a Gawker media post.
But I ultimately did it
because it was a reminder
to keep this project going,
because life gets in the way.
And at Google, maybe
some of your products
get sidled or put
on the back burner.
But ultimately, that
blog post really
helps you identify
where you stand.
And this is a guy named
Troy Carter who I talked to.
He used to manage Lady Gaga.
He's a wonderful guy.
He managed Lady Gaga and Eve,
the rapper, Biggie Smalls,
aka Notorious BIG, for
those playing at home.
And he was a club
promoter back in the day.
And now he's gone on to invest
in companies like Uber and Lyft
and Dropbox as an
angel investor.
And we talked about
pivoting with him,
because he wanted to
be a hip hop artist.
He grew up in West
Philadelphia, born and raised.
So of course, his idols were
the Fresh Prince and Jazzy Jeff.
So he pitched them
in their studio
after stocking them for a
couple days, maybe weeks.
And he realized his passion was
in behind-the-scenes producing
and managing talent.
So he told me that
you need to have
that personal internal
gauge tell you
when it's time to pivot.
And oftentimes,
people may not know
that Twitter was originally
a podcast network.
Twitter was a podcast
network called Odeo.
But they realized at
the time that Apple
was going to dominate
the podcasting landscape.
Instagram was originally
a check-in device
like Foursquare, where you
could tell people your location.
But they got the
market feedback.
And they pivoted to
make their idea better.
And ultimately, pivoting comes
down to moments in your career
or with your products.
But with Troy, I
asked him, how do
you go from being a talent
manager in the music industry
to being a prolific angel
investor in tech companies?
And he told me--
it was really funny--
he said, well,
there's curiosity,
because I wanted
to know if there
was life on Mars
in Silicon Valley as
a music executive.
And they wanted to know
if there was life on Mars
as a music industry veteran.
And there was mutual curiosity.
And he waited a
year before he even
did an investment, because he
wanted to survey the landscape.
So pivoting doesn't
mean just, hey, I'm
going to stop what I'm doing
and actually change my tracks.
It means I'm going to enhance
what I'm doing and leverage
my opportunities and
build on my network,
because I have established
myself in one field.
And I can transition
that to another.
So that is what
we're sharing today
in the influencer economy with
how to launch and collaborate
and thrive.
And this is the part where I
talk about some pun related
to stand-up comedy,
because people always say,
you need to tie
it back to comedy.
So I'll just give
you one example
of what I learned through
stand-up was that you always
got to finish your set.
That was the hardest part
was when I was doing sets
at open mics or at The Improv
where I reached my peak,
was you always have your set
list on a cocktail napkin,
whether you're drinking
a beer or water.
And you have your jokes.
You know, bands have
it as well onstage.
And they have their set down.
And I got heckled so hard at
this dive bar in Baltimore
that people were
calling like, look at me
and think of any insult
that stereotypically
you could make for me.
And that's what they gave me.
And I gave up on my set.
And that's the advice I'd give
to anyone with stand-up comedy
or writing a book or launching a
product, is never get deterred,
and always follow your
methods and your philosophy
and finish your set.
Because even if you get
through it and you bomb,
there's always the next
gig that you can go to.
Thank you very much for
checking this out today.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: I'd love to hear from
you just a little bit about how
you've maybe shared some
of those same principles
that you walked us
through, but in your life.
How have you applied
some of this, Ryan?
RYAN WILLIAMS: So for starters,
I mentioned I have a podcast.
If it was present day, I would
not start a podcast right now,
because it's so
competitive and noisy.
But when I started
it three years ago,
I was an early adopter.
And it was unique.
So I could land a lot
of A-plus interviews
with people like Seth
Godin or Brad Feld
that I couldn't get unless
I had been an early adopter.
And so that was a
characteristic that I realized
that I was fortunate
to have, and that all
these influential people
I interviewed always
thought about tech
to enable them.
And then equally, having
that platform of a podcast
could get me in the door with
people that ordinarily may not
be interested in
what I'm working on,
because as you know,
I worked at Machinima
and these big startups, and all
these companies maybe you've
never even heard of.
And so why would these
influential people talk to me?
But I pitched them on this
big vision with the book.
And who doesn't want
to be in a book?
Right?
And then also I had
a podcast that I'm
going to edit meticulously.
And it's on iTunes.
They can share it
with their friends.
And who doesn't want to
talk about themselves
for 45 minutes?
So those two elements
really got reinforced
as I kept doing the
research for the book.
AUDIENCE: So how
did you make people
come to the basketball games?
RYAN WILLIAMS: This group
was an insurgent group.
For those of you
that study marketing,
it's always good
to have an enemy.
Google started
off with an enemy.
My enemy in this PowerPoint is
celebrities like Kim Kardashian
and Seacrest.
And so our enemies actually
were the Memorial Maniacs.
If you were there
with this group,
they did things by the book.
Let's just say that.
And so The Psychos is
the group I started.
And I stole the movie
font from the movie
and put it on a t-shirt.
And then Hitchcock, he's
known for his outline,
his soliloquy outline.
So I took it in Cornelius
Vanderbilt silhouette.
And I put it on the
back of the t-shirt.
And I was the anti [INAUDIBLE].
We're going have fun.
We're gonna have parties
before and after.
And I made it more
of an experience.
So win or lose, you had
that connected community.
And also I went to
school with a lot
of fragmented fraternities
and sororities
and different organizations.
So this was like a
neutral party and location
where we could all get
together and rally and yell.
And our team ultimately didn't
even make the NCAA tournament
when I started it.
But I think having that
community and that connectivity
with others, maybe--
I think a lot of people
want to meet folks outside
of their network.
That's why Twitter and Facebook
and all these communities
exist, in some ways, because
you want to go out-of-network.
It's like helping people
meet other folks that they
wouldn't have met in college
was actually a big part of it.
And the basketball
was secondary.
It was really the
community part of it.
Nice recall.
I like that question.
AUDIENCE: So do you tend to
have one project you focus on
at a time?
Or do you tend to have several
projects going at once?
RYAN WILLIAMS: I have lots
of products going at once.
Like I learned from Brad Feld
about piloting your ideas.
As long as it doesn't
take up too much time.
Like I prioritize my podcast,
my book, my consulting business.
I have an online course
inspired by the book.
Actually someone from the crowd
when I book toured this summer,
said hey, you should put
this into an online course.
And so I just transferred all
the data into a video series.
And ultimately, I feel like
the strength I've found
is to be influential is if you
can repurpose your message--
there's a book called
"Making Ideas Happen"
by a guy named Scott Belsky.
He started up Behance that
was acquired by Adobe.
And he talks about how you need
to be agnostic to the platform,
but be mission-centric.
So your mission should
always be true to anything
you do, whether it's
writing a book, a podcast,
your consulting
business, a course,
or any product you make.
And that's a great way
to help you prioritize
what to focus on, because if you
start going outside your lane,
then you can realize that hey,
maybe I'm veering off too much.
But I believe strongly about
piloting new ideas/ even if you
write a blog post
that no one reads,
but it got something off
your chest and makes you feel
better, and you can share it
to five people in your network.
Then, there's value in that.
AUDIENCE: This is a topic that
a lot of people talk about.
And I just think that there's
a lot of real content there.
Very, very interesting.
Thank you for that.
On your point about
metrics, so you know,
reality is, a lot of
the social networks
and the places in which people
congregate on the internet
are all about subscribers,
likes, and things like that.
Right?
And you said that this
doesn't necessarily
mean whether or not you are
on important influencer.
But I guess for people
who are arriving
at any piece of content
from the outside, that's
the only thing they
have at moment zero.
Right?
RYAN WILLIAMS: Right.
AUDIENCE: It's like as it
becomes the ethos a little bit
in a certain way.
So how do you break this
ice when you're starting out
and you know you have
something good to offer.
But you're going to have to
be faced with this rejection
at first with your low numbers?
RYAN WILLIAMS: Oh, yeah.
You're going to be
wholeheartedly rejected
at first.
I see a lot of people through
the course of my career
that they build
this amazing thing.
And it's like an empty
house when they launch it.
And they're like, say,
where are the customers?
I thought people would buy my
book or download my product.
And they don't realize
that you consistently
have to be in a
phase of relaunching,
and that you pivot, you
listen to the market,
you get the feedback,
and then you relaunch.
The internet has an
incredibly short memory.
Right?
Mistakes we made at
Machinima on YouTube,
we could just take
the video down.
People forget.
Imagine the inundation
of information
we get through social
media every day.
People make mistakes.
You own it.
And you move on.
And I think ultimately,
perseverance
is really-- like you
have to have a bigger
vision, because you can
get lost in the weeds.
Like if you start a
pilot, a project--
let's say you're writing a blog,
and there's no bigger purpose,
then you're going to lose focus.
So if you can tie it
into a longer term
opportunity for yourself
and say, this is a channel.
This is a platform.
I'm building an alpha
prototype for a product.
And I want to get to beta.
Because that's going
to get me to launch.
And doing smaller milestones
for a bigger vision.
I feel like wrapping
those two up together is
a recipe for success,
because ultimately, it's
so easy to lose focus because
we're incredibly busy.
And so if you don't have a
bigger mission or purpose--
and sometimes that
takes time to discover.
And if you don't just
put yourself out there,
then you'll never know.
And so if you start
something now,
getting back to your
part of your question
about making it pop or
making it successful,
it's really finding
that validation.
Like, with my podcast, I've had
some fairly well-known people
that I didn't invite on the show
as Episode number 3's guest.
You know, I built
up 25 episodes.
And then I knew
Willie Geist, who's
hosted "The Today
Show," from college.
And I reached out to
him at Episode 25.
And I said, I have
this valid audience.
I started writing the book.
And so don't go after
influencers too early.
It's like they can
really help jet fuel
to get your product to
market in an accelerated way.
And then equally
once they're there,
make sure your
website doesn't crash.
Make sure your
product doesn't break.
Like, I was on the front page of
Reddit with one of my podcasts.
And I have children.
And I was like walking
my kid down the street.
And I see this woman's tweet.
And she's part of a community
called Rooster Teeth, which
is a YouTube network.
She tweets out my link.
And I'm like freaking out.
My kid, and I'm pushing
her down the street.
And I ran home.
And it was just like,
what's going on here?
Is my website stable?
Because I got that surge.
And so really having the
technology proved out.
And if your website breaks,
that's a great problem to have.
AUDIENCE: So your
presentation is
focused on consumer goods and
performances and things that
mostly are products being
marketed out there to people.
What about for things
like political mindshare?
Could the same general
ideas and concepts
be applied to something
like a political campaign?
RYAN WILLIAMS: Absolutely.
I think getting into
the heart of the matter
with finding problems
and people's needs.
So politics is
interesting in two ways.
One is how you reach people
during the campaign season
to find their problems to
then make them feel heard,
and say, I'm working on this.
I'm solving this
problem with you.
I think that the most
phenomenal political campaigns
are run like a tech product.
Right?
Where you do
gathering and surveys.
And you build the alpha.
You build that core
community of people
that are going to help
you reach a critical mass.
And then you reach out to
swing states if you're running
the president's.
And you have to make a
message that goes a little bit
more mainstream in most cases.
But ultimately,
that core community
of people whose
problems you're solving
is what's going
to get you there.
Like student debt for
college graduates.
That's a huge problem.
60 million people
are affected by it.
So if you run for
president, that's
a great market to
address and figure out
a way to solve that
problem with that community
like you would building
a product at Google.
And then secondarily,
how bills get passed
and how the back and
forth having open forums,
town halls to get
feedback on bills that you
want to pass, and have ideas.
And I look at it like if you
have 100 people that give you
advice from a random
sample set, if you
get one big idea from that
group, it's entirely worth it.
Right?
And it gets people
involved so they
can help you transcend
the message to other folks
to get them on board.
And I look at actually passing
bills with a tech angle
as well.
And that would be better
served with Congress
in passing with transparency,
listening to people's needs,
truly collaborating with
the community, and ideally
both sides of aisle.
AUDIENCE: I was just wondering.
Your book on Amazon has
200 reviews and all of them
five stars.
How did you do that?
RYAN WILLIAMS: So thank you
for checking out the reviews.
They're not vanity metrics.
They're real world metrics.
Right?
So I'll tell you just the truth.
I was approached by a
friend who is an author.
And I don't know if I should be
admitting this, but he said--
I self-published.
He said, if you
want a publisher,
then you need 100
Amazon reviews.
Because that's the one
percenter of books on Amazon.
So 1% of all books
have 100 reviews.
So he says you'll have that
social proof if you actually
get 100 reviews.
And then I'll introduce
you to my agent.
And you know, the
rest is history.
So the book's going
to come out next year.
We're translating into
Korean simultaneously.
And so 100 reviews
is a huge threshold.
So I would barter with people.
And if you came to my
book event this summer
in Raleigh, North Carolina,
and I'm signing books,
and you have a
long line of people
that are asking in-depth
questions, I would say, look.
If you leave me
an Amazon review,
if you honestly read the
book, I will give you
a free Skype consultation
when I go back to LA.
Right.
So I would barter with people.
And they would give me
amazing feedback on the book.
I look at a book like software.
And I'll publish 2.0 next year.
And I'll use that feedback
as part of the experience,
because people have told me
how I can make it better.
And so I found hooks
like that where--
like, I'm on the board
of my kids' preschool.
And a bunch of people
bought the book.
And there's that
phrase, "just ask."
Like, no one knows that
Amazon reviews are currency.
They don't know that
it's a bartering economy,
and that that matters to
people like me that are really
getting the word out there.
And the fact that
it was noticeable--
a Korean publisher-- I
had four people from Korea
reach out to me in three weeks.
And I imagine those
reviews really matter,
because you can get social proof
from the community, not just
influencers.
If you have a million
YouTube subscribers
and a bunch of Amazon reviews.
So I really bartered
with people,
because no one understood
really from my friends,
the people that would see it.
So anyone listening now, please,
if you leave an Amazon review,
honestly, that would be amazing.
And email me and tell me what
you think about the book,
because you have to open
yourself up to criticism.
And the reviews
actually are solid,
because it was the
right focus group
with the core community
of people who want
to read this type of content.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you very much.
RYAN WILLIAMS: Yeah.
Thank you.
Thank you, Peyton, and uh--
[APPLAUSE]